bilal tarabet nous a rejoint avec ses
cartes bonjour bilal bonjour marioupol
on l'a bien compris reste un des
objectif numéro 1 pour poutine tout à
fait d'abord je vais vous proposer de
regarder quelques quelques photos de
marioupol on va les voir aller voir
apparaître à l'écran les voilà en fait
ça c'est des photos qui ont été prises
par les seuls journalistes qui
travaillent pour une agence
internationale qui sont présents dans
mario paul depuis trois semaines dans la
ville dans la ville assiégée donc là
voilà on voit un immeuble l'envoi l'un
des nombreux cadavres dans la ville
d'ailleurs selon les autorités de mario
paul en fait le bilan et elles sont un
peu durs ces photos 1 le bilan est
impossible à établir réellement parce
que les bombardements sont continue ses
journalistes nous rapporte que parfois
les bombes tombent à raison d'une par
minute ce qui est ce qui est évidemment
énorme et qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent
ces trois journalistes qui sont présents
dans la ville ils nous disent que la
situation géographique de mario paul ce
sont leurs mots 1 est une malédiction
qui a misé la ville sur le chemin de la
conquête russe de la crimée alors là on
va passer à une carte de cette région du
front sud pour pouvoir comprendre en
fait pourquoi ces journalistes qui sont
là bas et qui qui témoignent tous les
jours de ce que dit marioupol nous dit
ça donc voilà pour rappel marioupol
c'est ici on a depuis le début de
l'offensive russe une un fonds fait une
à une armée qui part comme ça de la
crimée qui vient vers la ville de
l'ouest et on a les gens du les troupes
du don base qui descendent depuis las
vegas qu'on s'aperçoit on s'aperçoit que
marioupol c'est ce verrou qui
permettrait de rejoindre
ces régions du dombass donc les
séparatistes pro russes aux conquêtes
russe et à la crimée ici c'est une ville
qui permettrait de contrôler totalement
la mer d'azov c'est un port stratégique
dont par le blé le maïs est d'ailleurs
le siège de marioupol fait qu'il y a
déjà des problèmes d'approvisionnement
jusqu'au maghrébin de blé de maïs mais
aussi c'est un port d'exportation pour
toute la métallurgie qui est fabriqué ou
et bien qu'il est fabriqué dans les
usines du dombass donc vous voyez bien
que d'avoir cette mer d'azov c'est
extrêmement stratégique pour les russes
je rappelle que des avions russes ont
tiré des missiles depuis cette mer
d'azov jusque dans l'ouest de l'ukraine
et alors là je vous le montre sur la
carte on a un point ici qui s'appelle le
pont de crimes et qui a été construit en
2018 par vladimir poutine ici c'est la
russie continental et ces deux là
également que viennent tous les chars
russes pour rentrer en ukraine donc on
le voit bien ici sur cette carte
marioupol ça et alors là je reprends les
mots de ses journalistes sa situation
géographique qui aurait dû être une
bénédiction pour ses habitants et bien
c'est transformé en exactement inverse
s'est transformé en malédiction le
contrôle de la mer d'azov mais aussi le
contrôle de la mer noire qui est
important pour les russes et pour cela
ils doivent contrôler odessa exactement
balade du conte vallée de l'autre côté
de la carte ici donc odessa se trouve là
odessa n'est pas encore en cercle et
l'armée russe qui vient donc toujours de
crime ici est toujours bloqué à 120 130
km à peu près d'odessa ici à amicaux la
ive hier il y a eu quelques
bombardements qui n'ont pas fait de
victimes au sud d'odessa lors selon les
ukrainiens c'est pour tester les
défenses de la ville et odessa si vous
voulez c'est pareil c'est là c'est l'une
des portes d'entrée vers la mer noire
c'est un port d'exportation alors pour
le coup
d'hydrocarbures mais aussi de blé parce
qu'on sait que l'ukraine est un grand
pays agricole et alors vous voyez si on
repart de la crimée ici qui est central
d'avoir des ça permettrait de faire la
jonction avec ce territoire ici qui est
une république indépendantiste et qui
s'appelle la transnistrie pour gilles et
qu'il y ait en moldavie exact amérique
et en moldavie est alors j'allais dire
pour l'anecdote mais ce n'est pas du
tout une anecdote c'est que demain
demain la russie donc de vladimir
poutine va commémorer ou célébrer
j'imagine du point de vue de moscou
l'annexion de la crimée il y a huit ans
qui était exactement il ya huit ans le
18 mars 2014 on va quitter un moment le
sud de l'ukraine bilal on va partir à
kiev où les habitants peuvent de nouveau
sortir dans les rues le couvre feu a
pris fin ce matin il ya eu un mort un
civil qui a été touchée par les débris
d'un missile a battu les troupes russes
bilal tente toujours d'avancer et de
prendre le centre-ville de la capitale
mais pour l'instant il n'a pas de siège
à proprement parler sur kiev puisque la
route vers le sud est toujours libre est
toujours sous le contrôle des deux
ukrainiens tout à fait mais c'est même
la seule et là on va le voir sur la sur
la carte générale de l'ukraine c'est à
dire que concernant si vous voulez la
capitale elle est prise en tenaille
entre des troupes qui viennent de l'est
et des troupes qui viennent du nord
ouest qui viennent du nord ouest on le
sert sont bloqués par une résistance
d'ailleurs inattendue des ukrainiens en
banlieue nord-ouest ici haïr pin et les
troupes russes sont aussi bloqués
ici à l'est de la capitale donc hier on
l'a dit à tchernihiv d'aidé tiru son add
ons tué 10 personnes qui attendaient qui
attendait qu'ils faisaient la queue pour
acheter du pain dans une boulangerie le
maire de cars qui vivent ici qui est la
grande ville russophone de l'ouest ans
dont les russes s'attendaient à ce
qu'elle les accueille presque les bras
ouverts cette ville résiste encore selon
le maire 1 53 morts ak revivre rien dans
la journée d'hier donc encore une fois
pourquoi je pour pourquoi on dit tout ça
parce que on le voit tous les jours que
ce soit évidemment à marioupol hakkar
vivent à tchernihiv à kiev est ailleurs
il y a de plus en plus de victimes
civiles dans ce conflit et ça et bien
malheureusement c'est typique de ce
qu'on appelle là un état de siège ou une
guerre de siège c'est à dire quoi c'est
à dire que quand une armée ne peut plus
avancer on le sait on l'a décrypter
vladimir poutine pensait pouvoir rentrer
rapidement en ukraine et prendre le
pouvoir eh bien on s'attaque aux villes
on s'attaque au civil pour faire fuir la
population la moitié de la population de
kiev a déjà fui la ville on parle quand
même d'un million trois cent mille
personnes qui ont fui en ça n'est pas
rien pour démoraliser la population ce
qui reste vive dans des bunkers pour que
cette population demande à son pouvoir
politique
éventuellement finalement d'abandonner
voilà d'abandonner la partie c'est
exactement cette situation dans laquelle
on est le problème de l'état de siège
c'est que plus il dure et plus
finalement c'est l'effet inverse qui se
produit c'est à dire que si la
population ne cède pas et bien le moral
d acier gens s'en trouve renforcée mais
surtout la crédibilité
la crédibilité de
l'envahisseur si vous voulez
est totalement discréditée merci
beaucoup bill halter ab trouvé
d'explication karthala public elle